what's up gq my name is richard mendoza
owner of footy rich barber shop here in
new york city i own two barber shops one
in brooklyn and one in queens i've been
to barber for over 23 years and all i do
is like to make people look good today
we're going to recreate robert
pattison's haircut on michael let's
bring our client michael what's it going
rich man
yes thanks for doing this damn thank you
for coming i'm excited i'm excited to be
about to have an awesome makeover right
now i'm looking forward to it robert
pattinson is one of my favorite actors
[Music]
let's look at robert's hair evolution in
2005 i could see that he has a nice
little torso short top and a little
messy style front kind of wavy kind of
long 2008 his hair he's got a little bit
longer and messy but style with some
products that could talk 2010 he got a
little shorter on the sides kind of
clean face like yours and 2012 he has a
slick back that's actually a nice cut
too just a little palm mate his beard is
a little longer oh he went really sure
on the side he got a real like military
undercut style haircut that's cool it's
very european oh very this is more of
like a james themed style you know
longer sideburns 2015 was a good year
for robert oh wow 2016. he cut it all he
cut it all he's like i got tired of here
2017 he's pushing it forward give it a
little bit of a fringe look and then wow
this hair grew fast after two years
later in 2019 it's not slicking back
it's coming back where he was in 2008
and then 2022 that's a good time nice
little comb over nice and neat it's
clean i guess for a batman he had to
shave his face so you get that look and
then 2022 spring that's a cut real messy
on the top little short on the sides not
too short it's more softened i love this
look yeah two two let's do it let's do
it you ready
yeah
so i'm going to blow dry your hair
straighten out your hair i'm a man bunny
and then i'm going to give a horseshoe
guideline for myself so i can lay your
hair flat i'm going to add the clippers
and i'm going to soften texture with a
scissor to make it look like it's not
barber style more of a styling look i'm
gonna cut from the top but make sure i
give a longer length and i'm gonna work
myself lower we're gonna give you a nice
little shave and you're gonna look like
robert
and then after that add a little
products and we're gonna shift from the
left side and the right side of the
hairstyle so he knows how to work with
sierra after we're done with this you
ready
all right
[Music]
this is crazy when's the last time you
blew dry hair i don't think you ever
blow dry your hair don't ever blow your
hair like i wake up this is my hair and
i'm out the door yeah
but we're gonna give you a look where
you could style during the day style
during the night and just give you this
nice short haircut vibe
[Music]
now i just straighten out your hair a
little bit and i'm going to do a
horseshoe part and i'm going to split it
to give me a guideline so i can lay it
flat it's rare for me to get a haircut
and i went recently but i didn't know
how to explain the style that i wanted i
wanted this you know robert pattinson
look where it's like short on the sides
and you kind of have it longer up top
and be able to go either way i always
tell my clients is i like to see a
reference to pictures and what we just
saw earlier it was actually the perfect
example for me to give you the right
guideline of the haircut you want to
make the magic so right now i'm gonna
take the clipper four
i'm just gonna run it up
when's the last time you had a clipper
on the side of your head it's been four
years
so i usually run the clipper just to
take the bulk out and then after i take
the bulk out i use the scissors to
lighten up and soften the sides
this is a horseshoe guy like it's more
like i'm giving him an undercut and then
i'm going to start blending it through
and mix it around with his hair
[Music]
all right
we take down the sides with the clip
four
give it a nice little balance after that
now i'm gonna trim the top i'm gonna
leave the front longer and the back a
little shorter
[Music]
all your hair is really curly and it's
really thick hair i'm always playing
with a different hairstyle yeah it's
been long in the past i've been doing it
shorter but trying to keep the curls so
i'm giving myself a guideline for the
back when i cut here i make sure like
everything's like straight box up and
then i start horizontally the sides
i don't want the back to match where
it's going to look like one shape all
around i want to give the front more of
like a pump but also once you put
products we could style it with it i'm
leaving a little bit more
hair on the side a little longer so it
matches from your chin
to your top of your head i don't want to
cut too in that might give you like a
military look how do you recommend
people choose their haircut anybody
could pull off any haircut you're the
person who carries your look you're
giving yourself an image so if you're
out acting or singing you're trend
setting you know like oh i want to look
like you because you have the coolest
hairstyles that's why you go to reach
the barber
all right so now i'm going to go to your
sides and soften the haircut because i
did a buzz cut
so right now i'm taking my trimmer and
just clean around his ears
i also like to just blend this off
since we're going to give you a
quick shave to clean up your face so how
to take care of your haircut is like if
you feel like it's too long that's the
time to go get erica this haircut style
is more like i'll see you once a month
oh i love that i noticed you you cut
your back you did this yourself i did
yeah
so
i'm gonna just uh blend it because it's
kind of messy
all right so let's shave your face and
then after that we add the products
[Music]
i'm going to blow dry your hair again
your natural curl is coming out so we're
just going to try to straighten it out
with a blow dryer i blow with hot air so
it helps you direct the hair where i
want it to go then when i add cold air
it locks the hair
just me locking the hair with cold air
it's now giving that robert haircut
style look you can actually see it right
now there's no products to make it more
fine and having a good shape so right
now i'm using the hanzo fuco claymation
helps me hold down the front and you
know i can add a little texture powder
also if you want to do pomade you can
slick the back those are the three
styles that you can use with the three
products how to put products on your
hair
is
you make sure it's all over your hand so
all the products
in the back
and then the leftovers in the front
it's like you're ready to go out so the
trick is you get your front of your hair
and just twist it
and just let it fall wherever it wants
to take you you know styling is is hard
so always open your fingers go with the
flow you can see the cut is nicely
textured and put together
[Music]
all right you ready to see it let's do
it all right let's go
oh my gosh
this looks amazing
thank you so much so good yo
i love it the tips are so cool and they
like twist
so a quick maintenance wash your hair
every other day you want the true oils
to come out of your skin and and put
some volume to your hair if there's a
powder for the morning and i put in
claymation so it's more wax and if you
want to like style at night you can add
pomade and slick it back so you have
like those three choices see me every
once a month okay for that for a nice
little clean up on the sides and i say
your top is every two months you get you
get a nice trim i got you a gillette lab
to help you clean your face thank you
here's the shaver and the cream and get
you nice and smooth appreciate it i
appreciate it thank you
thank you
that was robert's short spiky haircut
thank you for having me peace
[Music]